[Music]
pitch perfect in this movie you rap is
that correct yes because when you think
Anna Kendrick you think hip hop's
yeah yeah I'm getting a real hip-hop
vibe from you I have to say I know yeah
no it was humiliating
well within the context of the movie I
was I'm supposed to be bad at it like in
the movie in the scene I'm like
embarrassed and I'm bad at it and it's
funny and so that's fine but then for
the soundtrack they wanted me to like do
it for real it's the dr. Dre rap from no
diggity and so I had to go into a
recording studio
and do it like for real and there were
and there were like these two cool like
music producer guys there and they were
like like just go for it and I just like
get mad get angry like you know just
harness that side of yourself I was like
okay so like I had to put myself in this
zone where I was like standing like a
guy and I was like imagining that I had
a penis and I was like you know
surrounded by like [ __ ] and no it's
doing the hit and I went home my friends
were like oh no are you doing like the
hand motions and I was like I was I
created a whole scenario and battery
there was an imaginary extras in this
story and I was degrading them and
we'll be available for purchase I can't
actually want to hear that I want to
hear that this would be great Conan no
I'm not laughing you know I've wrapped
in my day
I wonder we we actually we just talked
about tweets earlier in the show and and
and you seem to tweet a lot about Taco
Bell I'm curious about that because you
know we just check out because that's
where people reveal their true nature
are you late at night on Twitter yeah
why do you what's your obsession to talk
about I love and you're not you're not
they're not paying you or anything
you're just you know that would be great
yeah I mean you know no yeah I well it's
like a kind of secret it's like a dirty
thing that I love talk about so much
like I cannot I cannot eat Taco Bell
before midnight looks like a reverse
friend ones saying like I can't it's
just so filthy that I can't do it it's
like it has to be under cover of
darkness the money from so you need to
do it but you need to do it it's like
it's a it's a shameful act but it's so
good right so what do you do you you go
after me I'll go like you know in my
I'll go through I thought I like drive
out on my way to get to the one with a
drive-thru so I don't have to go inside
right and then I'll just eat it perfume
on my car
soon you'll be able to do that when the
when the album comes out you can sit in
there and listen to your rap well if not
you not have a penis it's the name of
the track actually